well hopefully we'll get to the four as
well depending on how how long this
takes so hi everyone pleasure to be here
among atigun and faculty at UC Berkeley
and I work on getting robots to work for
and with and around people I think
what's special about robots is that they
can take these actions that change the
physical state of the world and the
problem that we try to solve in robotics
is what actions might the robot take
what sequence of actions what trajectory
even what policy it should a dot that
end up ends up maximizing the robots
utility buddy which which is how we tend
to capture the rope what the robots task
is and the community in the community
we've made a lot of progress on this so
here's a video from Boston Dynamics that
shows a robot sort of opening a door and
walking through it and what's kind of
interesting about this video is that the
robot can do that despite even the
changing environment and the
disturbances that this person is
applying to it right so because it can
keep on reoptimize in its behavior it
can actually adapt what it's doing to
new environments and new situations and
be robust against disturbances here's a
baby version of this right it's much
more tame this is in my lab and here you
see a robot that it's doing a fairly
good job carrying the cup from one point
to another while kind of reacting
robustly to me trying to mess with it
try to I keep pushing it down and sort
of keeps on keeping the cup upright and
moving along it's bad so this is great
and so where we are in robotics today is
that we can handle disturbances and
obstacles fairly well and there's been a
lot of progress in optimizing robot
objective functions utility functions in
spite of these sort of disturbances and
in different kinds of environments and
for different applications also of
course there's a long way to go but
taking a look back at this video what's
interesting is that one interpretation
is that the robot is doing a great job
because it's robust against
trying to mess with it another way to
think about it is that maybe just maybe
I'm not there to mess with it but maybe
just maybe what's actually happening
here is that the robot is doing the task
and not tried the correct way maybe it's
keeping the cup kind of too high up and
so I'm worried that if it drops it they
will actually I would know break my
favourite cup and what I'm trying to do
is I'm actually trying to correct its
behavior so if you now adopt this lens
the robot is not doing such a fantastic
job anymore because I keep on trying to
teach it something to correct it and it
keeps on stubbornly going back and doing
the task in the old way it's used to
doing and instead what an ideal robot
should do is I should correct it and
then it should understand what I'm
trying to communicate to it and it
should adapt its understanding of the
task and do the task differently as a
consequence of my intervention and so
that's ideal but to do this we have to
stop assuming that people are obstacles
or disturbances right then we have to
get robots to actually treat us as
people what for whatever that means and
so that's the general challenge that my
lab is working on so in a nutshell what
we work on is enabling robots to account
for people and the way that they
generate their actions and so that means
asking questions like how should I
define the robotics problem in light of
the fact that robots are gonna have to
deal with people and what does this mean
for the algorithms that I'm gonna use to
solve robotics problems and in
particular I'm I'm gonna claim they're
actually three not just not one but
three kinds of people that my robot will
need to deal with so the obvious kind of
person that enters robot existence is
the end user right so this is difficult
what we have in mind when we build
robots we build them to help someone and
that someone is the end user this is the
person in
was home I'm putting the robot for an
autonomous car this is the passenger in
the car that the robot is supposed to
take to a particular destination so
that's the end user and that's one very
important kind of person but not the
only one so if you think of the fact
that we're designing these robots to
work in human environments that means
that we're designing them to work around
humans and so there's a second kind of
person that ends up being important and
that's all the people who are gonna be
around the robot as it's doing its tasks
so I send my robot off to the cafeteria
and it's not gonna do that in isolation
it's gonna have to navigate around
people it's going to have to move its
arm around baby other arms that are
moving and so on and so forth and so the
robot doesn't just have to do the task
that I asked it to do it has to do it
while in a sense making sure that the
actions that it's taking end up meshing
well with the actions that people in the
environment are taking that's the second
kindness the person in the environment
not the person that the robot is
actually supposed to help but the person
who is there now taking actions in the
same world as the robot is taking
actions in and then there's one more
who's the third we have we've covered
the end user we've covered the people
around yeah so we don't really tenth in
human robot interaction you know we
usually think about this and so we're
kind of starting to think about this but
but there's this third person involved
and what's interesting about the
designer the developer is that so we
designers robot designers are people too
and the fact that we're people all means
that we're fallible it means that were
not magic Oracles it means that were not
perfect sources of information and what
we're discovering is that robots might
have to take that into account if
they're actually supposed to work
robustly and do their job well and so my
lab is working on how you get robots to
account for all these three kinds of
piece
and I tend to break up the problem into
two categories one of them is how yes
let's optimize utility but how do you
get the robot to optimize its utility
when it's not doing that in isolation
but it actually has to do it in
coordination with people so it has to
make sure that the actions that it's
taking ends up end up meshing well
gelling well with the actions that
people are taking what are their the
end-user or the or just people around
and then the second one is okay what
utility right how do I figure out what
utility the robot should optimize for in
the first place what's the right utility
you had a question yes with respect to
the midi planner resolution question
around resolution in the middle category
do you do distinguish from sort of
garden-variety user from say a user who
is being augmented like this but by my
robotic device you with with prosthetics
being at one end of a spectrum but not
just but maybe a third hand being
stylized situation where it's really
augmentations yeah so there so for the
end user you can think of the robot as
being either a tool or a peer
collaborating with the person and both
of those situations are things that we
do research on and we deal with they're
obviously slightly different and even
for the same kind of robot people might
approach in the interaction slightly
differently so that makes for a fun
thing don't work on identifying it at
least with respect to say safety there's
the pathway through this through the
developer that's things like liability
and responsibility mm-hmm we'll probably
travel so there's no scope here but
right well I'm not gonna talk about
liability I'm just gonna talk about how
you might technically formulate the
problem these these two problems but the
closer we're going to get to that is
when the end user ends up writing down
there's the specification for the robot
you know should you trust that what does
that mean etc etc so what Jack hopefully
a little bit about that okay so
coordination and then figure now what
utility to even optimize in the first
place those are those we figured those
are the two problems
no we're interested in and so I want to
start with the first one which is the
coordination now I want to share with
you a little bit about the coordination
today some of our work in this area
in particular as it relates to
autonomous driving so I should clarify I
get to work on on these problems as they
apply to cars that way mom I'm a
research scientist there but and it's
super exciting to work on getting these
things out on real cars but today I'm
going to be just a clarified I'm gonna
be talking from the perspective of me as
Berkeley faculty not from the
perspective of me as though any kind of
way more employee in fact this is
actually a picture that memo has made
available publicly so the autonomous
driving problem right I have a car and
let's say that I've done perception and
I've detected all these other agents
around in my environment now what do I
do
so what we'd like is for the car to
figure out what trajectory it should
execute what action it should execute
going forward and we'd like for that
action to maximize the car's utility
whatever utility function we specified
the challenges that how good or any
particular plan is for a car it actually
depends on what people and the
environment are going to end up doing
alright so the car wants to avoid
collisions with people at the very least
maybe he wants to stay out of their way
etc etc and so I have this dependence on
the robots utility of the robots utility
function on what people end up doing and
what's interesting is that it's not
enough to reason just about where the
person currently is alright if you want
to do a good job figure now what you
should do next you have to figure out
what people might
so you have a prediction problem now
I've only started working on autonomous
driving when I started at Berkeley but
I've encountered this sort of human
prediction problem all the way back in
my grad school days so here's a when I
was working on shared autonomy here's me
in an earlier grad school version of me
and what I'm doing here is I'm operating
this robot to try to do some simple
tasks like pick up this bottle you can
see it's very hard it's tedious right I
mean it's hard when you're not actually
doing the task yourself and you have to
kind of control this other entity to do
it and so what did we think here well we
thought hey instead let's have the robot
try to predict what it is that I'm
trying to do and then use that
prediction to start helping me in
achieving the task that I want so then
the robot assistance kicks in and it
simplifies the task greatly for me so
the question was how are we going to
make this this prediction of what the
person will do next right we had the
exact same human prediction problem for
the robot to figure out what it should
do it had to know what I'm planning on
doing in the future and the key idea
here was to treat people as to assume
that their actions are approximately
rational to assume that their actions
are that they're deciding on their
actions in a way that's driven by their
goals or utilities or whatever it is
that they're trying to achieve and so
when it comes to autonomous driving - we
could do the same thing we could say
well what is the person gonna do what we
can assume is that the person is gonna
optimize Realist approximately optimize
their own utility function and if we got
access to that somehow now the robot can
actually plug that into it
and in that prediction that predicted
human plan into its own optimization and
figure out what's the best thing for it
to do so I call this the predict then
react approach to human robot
interaction because it's all about the
robot trying to figure out what you're
planning on doing next and then reacting
to that and this sort of
thing has been pretty successful at
enabling robots to do their job while
staying out of people's way right so you
predict where people want to go you
figure out how to do your tasks without
getting in their way and intersecting
with their path now this is nice and a
lot of applications but unfortunately
robots that only stay out of everyone's
way
are not always the best and the
autonomous driving application makes
that painfully obvious so here's an
autonomous car in orange and it needs to
switch to the left lane to take an exit
and you can see there's a bunch of cars
in total and the left lane if you try to
predict what people will do that's
pretty easy what people will do given
the history of their actions so far yes
basically they're gonna keep going
forward that that's a very easy
prediction task in this case and the
challenge is that now when the robot is
actually computing what it should do in
response right it's optimizing its own
utility saying I want to go into the
left lane but I also want to avoid
collisions and I know that these people
are gonna keep moving forward well it
has kind of two options you can slow
down and wait for a big enough gap in
traffic right and then end up pissing a
bunch of people off or it could miss the
exit keep going forward not slow down
miss the exit and then you know if I'm
the passenger it will it will piss me
off because I'm I don't get to come here
on time and give this talk so that's a
problem as well so the both of those
choices don't look so great
similarly imagine a four-way stop where
again here's my robot here's some people
trying to go very easy to predict what
they're gonna do right you see them
coming they're gonna they're gonna go
through the intersection that's what
they want to do that's what their plan
is and now you're gonna plan to stay out
of the way and you know again you're
gonna be pissing some people off and I'm
not making this up there's actual
reports of this sort of thing happening
so this is an article that describes how
good an autonomous car that's stuck at
in one of these four-way intersections
because
people kept on inching forward the car
would predict that they're gonna go
would stay out of their way right then
the next person then the next person
eventually test driver takes over so
this I should say that we sort of saw
this coming when we were doing shared
autonomy because in shared autonomy what
would happen was that at some point one
of the robots assistants would kick in
people would stop providing input just
be like okay you got this go so we
already saw that what our robot was
doing was ended up changing the human
behavior influencing what people do and
um now we change domains and this wasn't
a very big deal then but now because we
change domains all of a sudden it became
a very big deal where if you think about
this sort of situation right I wouldn't
wait for a big enough gap in traffic
that might never happen and I wouldn't
miss the exit ID or what I would do is I
would nudge into the left lane the
person behind would slow down very
likely sometimes not but very likely
would slow down let me in and I would
actually be able to take my exit most
people are nice that's that's how I
would actually get around this now
unfortunately the predict and react
approach to interaction would never come
up with some maneuver like this right
because the predict and react approach
says predict what our people plan on
doing then get yourself out of the way
so it is fundamentally missing is it
fails to account for the fundamental
fact that whenever our robots are acting
they end up affecting changing what
people are doing so we're sort of
totally oblivious to that and so this is
in a sense a problem and that this is
happening and we need to deal with it on
the other hand like we saw it's an
opportunity because maybe leveraging
this sort of effect that robot actions
have on human actions might actually get
us to systems that are overall more
efficient for everyone so robots that
can actually coordinate better and make
things that seem impossible in a predict
and react paradigm actually start
seeming pause
so what's interesting is that people
they're not obstacles they're not
disturbances they actually make
decisions but that's something we knew
for a while but what's even more
complicated is that they don't make
these decisions in isolation they
actually take the reason about the robot
they take what the robot is going to do
is doing into account so the challenge
here is that if you think of the right
way to approach human robot interaction
is it's game theoretic right you have a
game where there's a human state there's
a world state there's a robot state
these two players can each take actions
they might have the same action space or
different action spaces and they tend to
have different utility functions so
that's a game now just to solve that
right you'd basically have to compute an
equilibrium which or it's kind of
implicitly capture that the person is
reasoning about the robot the robot is
reasoning about the person and they're
influencing each other the issue is that
we live in a continuous state in action
world and we have to make these
decisions in real time and so then for
us the question became how do we is
there a way to still maintain
tractability computational efficiency
for such state spaces action spaces and
computational demands while capturing
this interesting aspect of game
theoretic interaction where we actually
account for the fact that there's this
influence going on how do we do that
and so what we came up with is an
approach based on the idea of an under
actuated system so this is work by dursa
where what so if you don't know what a
non-directory system is so that here's a
very simple example what I can do is I
can actuate this I can fold a cart left
and right when I do that this pendulum
ends up moving I don't have a motor on
this so I don't get to control this
pendulum but my utility the pen
on what I do here but very importantly
what happens here as well because I'm
trying to get this balanced so this is a
classic example and so we thought that
this might be a paradigm that some
interactions could fit into as well
because if I think of driving I have
control over I get to decide the
controls of my of my robot I do not get
to decide what the human does but what
does happen is that when I change what I
do here this changes so I have influence
over what happens in a sense with the
humans actions or humans degrees of
degrees of freedom so instead of doing
the predict and react approach what we
did is we thought hey let us not have
people make decisions in isolation but
actually start taking what our car is
doing into account so their utility
actually depends on what we decide to do
and so the answer that we get for what
they're gonna do depends on our
trajectory so SCI H is now an actual
function of say R this is not actually
solving the full game this is just
saying the person is going to compute a
best response to the robot so we're
simplifying the game heavily when we do
this yeah
considering the sequential problem and
what's going to happen so so we reduced
it to a single-shot game because
basically what happens now is that the
robot is proposing a trajectory and the
person is computing a best response to
that but we're doing this in a model
predictive control framework where
what's going to happen is that the robot
will take that first action the person
will act and then everything is going to
get replant all over again and that's
again because if I had to deal with a
sequential game from the get-go
I mean I don't know how to do with that
so so now the we end up with this nested
optimization problem where the robot is
thinking what should I do
such that when the person responds to
what I'm doing it overall works out well
for me
you can think of this as if I'm at a
conference right the and I'm trying to I
see Peter across the room and I want to
talk to Peter right there sort of
predict and react approach to
interaction would say predictive Peter
wants to talk to me if Peter wants to
talk to me I approach Peter and talk to
him if not then not right and here what
we're doing is we're giving the robot a
bit of a more active role in the
interaction where we're saying look
Peter might or might not want to talk to
me now but let me actually approach
Peter because I predict that if I
approach Peter chances are he's gonna
want actually so so we can actually get
to change the outcome based on based on
deciding different things with the
robots actions this is still even though
we've simplified the game this is still
a nested optimization which is difficult
to solve in again in real time so we do
model predictive control we solve this
with a quasi Newton optimization method
and to take a gradient of u R with
respect to C R we end up using an
implicit differentiation trick
to get around this nested optimization
problem and we've also experimented with
and sort of an iterated kind of I don't
even know what to call it I'd say
coordinate ascent type of approach where
we fixed one we
generate the the person's right either
in a best response typewriter I generate
one I figure out what the person would
do I keep that fixed I figure out what
the robot would do so that's something
that seems to work pretty well as well
and so what happens is you might
initialize like this but then you
realize that if the robot starts going
left the person's best response is going
to be to slow down and then you can
actually die works out better for the
robots utility so you'll preferred that
solution yeah communication here is only
in manifested behavior not in some
knowledge above the utility functions so
so far good a good question so so far
and we're gonna get to that so far in
order for me to do all of this I need to
have a model of the person's utility
function yeah yeah right so and what's
more what I'm assuming about the
person's knowledge is actually I'm
assuming this is and this is a fairly
big assumption remember we reduced this
to a static stackelberg game so at every
step for the whole time horizon I'm
giving the person access to my whole
plan that only works well for pretty
short time horizons otherwise it assumes
that people can already think you know
15 seconds ahead to what the robot is
gonna do so there's there are there are
many there's a sequence of
approximations here that we needed to
take while still trying to capture this
reactive in a mutual influence aspect
but getting this on an actual car right
so that's been the balancing act
yeah tends to give a lot of power to the
first player then you can basically
ultimatum so you expect a guy that you
just to be very aggressive do you
observe that did you and I'll get to
that let me let me answer your question
and
right so sir that's what happens now
going going back to your question I
think about what did we assume about the
person's utilities right I can only do
this if I know the person's utility I
can actually do this computation and so
in reality I don't the persons and I'm
gonna capture that by some hidden
parameters data that the robot does not
get to observe so you can think of these
in the driving scenario as for instance
I might know different aspects that a
person is likely to care about like
efficiency related aspects safety
related aspects but I don't necessarily
know the exact trade-offs that a driver
is making between those different
aspects and so I'm gonna encapsulate
that in a parameter called theta and
unfortunately this parameter is hidden
so our first our first idea is a natural
starting point for dealing with this was
to learn utility function for human
driving based on historical data so we
collected a bunch of data of people
driving around other other agents and
then we set up this optimization problem
that said with a maximum likelihood
estimation that said find the theta that
maximizes the probability of the human
trajectories that I've seen and the
Assumption here is what is the
probability that I'm gonna see a
trajectory given a particular theta well
it's going to be higher if the utility
according to that data is higher for
that trajectory this particular the fact
that this is a Boltzmann distribution
comes from an optimization for maximum
entropy and so that's why this is
motivated from but there there might be
different kinds of problem different
observation models you might want to use
there so that's what we did this is
Bayesian not even Bayesian this is
maximum entropy University reinforcement
learning if we hold a whole belief over
theta that would be called Bayesian
averse reinforcement learning so we come
up we look at human data we come up with
this data and then we plug it in
now what happens well what happens is
that the robot here let's say the robot
needs to merge into the left lane
instead of doing the predict and reactor
approach where the robot would let the
person go and merge behind if there's a
big enough gap in traffic if not wait
our car in some situations because again
it still has safety you know that cares
about safety and all of that but in some
situations the size it's actually safe
to march in front of the person because
it expects that the person will actually
slow down to accommodate for that so we
saw that which is which is an innocence
amazing because it captures that people
don't act in isolation but they actually
take the robot into account so that part
of our mission was great but there's
also very big limitations with
limitation with this which comes back to
your question so here is human human
interaction here's a truck driver
cruisin along a highway and we have a
first card that merges in and then we
have a second car this car puts its
blinker on tries to Marge in but a truck
driver does not slow down to accommodate
for that and it gets pretty messy so the
interesting thing here right is this is
the exact counter example this is the
kind of there might be many limitations
about the work that I just described but
I think the fundamental one is
essentially the stock truck driver we
assume that every person reacts in the
same way that every person it's
influenced by the robots action it's in
the same way and so what when we did
inverse reinforcement learning we
captured and it says the average driver
model but some people are not the
average driver and won't be act like
that what would happen if we try to
interact with this truck driver well it
would probably happen
is not this because at some point right
even something that keeps on stubbornly
thinking that the person is gonna break
realizes that even in that case there
won't be actually enough time to avoid a
collision so it would kind of get out of
the way but it's still not the kind of
situation you want to get yourself into
and so we could quickly realize that we
have to start actually adapting the
cards behavior to each individual user
we can't actually assume a universal
driver model aniversary human model we
actually have to start adapting our
understanding and so unnatural thing to
do here and again it took a few
approximations but the idea was keep a
probability distribution over over keep
a belief over this hidden parameter
theta that you get to update on it at
every step based on what you observe so
you might start off with some prior and
then the person this particular driver's
actions are gonna start changing your
estimate of what kind of driver they are
what utility they have when we did this
we were a little bit surprised because
essentially we the robot went back into
this very very very conservative mode
the reason that happened was because if
you look at different drivers the
nominal driver and maybe the truck like
driver they when you when you're driving
next to them right you start off with a
pretty conservative prior you say well
maybe they're more on the more on the
aggressive side and then you observe
their actions and you incorporate their
actions as evidence about what kind of
driver they are but their actions look
very similar if they're just driving
forward on a highway there's not much
information you get and so the robot
Nevers gather it never gathers enough
evidence to be to put enough probability
mass on okay this person is a defensive
or normal nominal kind of driver and so
it never actually attempts any kind of
margin front of the person
maybe this has taken this case study too
far but in human human situation it's
like hopefully the truck hit his horn
meaning that there was some other
communicate another communication
channel that existed was indicative of
intense more reliably right absolutely
so your if let me go back to this so so
let me answer that in 20 seconds
what's happening here is that we're
trying to figure out what kind of turtle
this is but and we might think it's the
nicest normal little turtle poking it
right and then you realize what monster
you're dealing with and so we're not
actually probing at the system we're
trying to observe at all we're just
trying to passively observe this driver
and so to answer your question the car
never attempts to go in front of the
person to trigger that horn or whatever
response right to update its estimate of
the model it just turned indicator the
indicator and I should say that all of
this is really based on just the
physical actions we haven't worked with
indicators and so on but they've kind of
fit naturally into this framework so so
what another thing you could do is put
your your your blinker on well sometimes
people don't respond to that and kind of
actually have to start merging towards
them but the point is because the robot
is it gets to actually influence what
people do we're not stuck with doing
estimation based on these actions what
we can do is we can seek robot actions
that then trigger human trajectories
human reactions that are actually
different based on the kind of driver
that we're dealing with if we get to do
that then all of a sudden regardless of
which driver we're dealing with we're
gonna get much more evidence more
quickly and actually know what to do and
so to do this which switch from a
passive estimation approach to an active
estimation approach where we thought hey
we could the robot that does this has
essentially
what let me say put it this way this is
a partially observed system you can
think of it as a palm DP where theta is
the hidden state the challenge is that
because we can't actually solve the full
system we're separating an estimation
from control so we're estimating things
and then always planning with our
current best guess and what that does is
it deprives the robot from knowing that
information itself has value the robot
is always reacting to the information
that it has but it never knows that
information can't doing things that
might not look so great according to the
current estimate but that gives you a
lot of information are useful and so the
way we address this is by actually
directly incentivizing information gain
and the objective and so that is the way
that we're able to kind of approximate
this partially observed system and what
ends up happening is the kind of
behavior that you'd want to see where
the course actually starts nudging
towards the person's lane not
necessarily committing to emerge but
doing this because and again we planned
this just directly in the control input
so nudging in is not an action that
somehow available to the robot but it
does this it comes up with that as the
optimal trajectory because then it gets
a lot of information from this driver if
the driver is a defensive driver they'll
slow down or you know not honk or
something right and then the car will
shift its probability mass on - okay I'm
dealing with a nominal driver and
complete its March if the person is like
our truck driver keeps going honks etc
then the car can update its model of the
person and know that it can't actually
complete the merge and has to retreat
back to its lane very cool things that
four-way stops where what the car
decides to do is actually very
interesting it it does sort of the same
thing in the beginning and then
depending on the kind of user is here
we're looking at distracted and
attentive users depending on the user is
dealing when it does different things so
here the car decides to nudge into the
intersection inch forward into the
intersection that's the common part and
so here this is an information-gathering
action or it can be interpreted as such
weird attentive drivers it can actually
they'll break the car will know and
continue with drivers that don't break
that keep on going that's okay the car
updates its model and in this case what
our car does is it gets itself out of
there there's no one in the back so you
can actually move backwards so the car
gets out of the way and so that the
person can safely go very very the way
this is Mike okay my favorite example is
when we switch this around a little bit
so far the car was always optimizing for
its own selfish utility I want to be I
want to get to my destination I want to
do so efficiently now we made the car
actually be a polite car that tries to
get people through the intersection
first as quickly as possible so that's
in the utility function and what the car
decides to do is it doesn't just sit
there and wait for the person do I go do
you go do I go do you go wait for the
person to realize that they can go the
car starts inching backwards from the
intersection which I've never seen a
human do ever so this took us by
surprise the reason it happens is
because the the model that it's learned
of this human driver right is that this
guy's trying to be safe as well and
efficient so by removing yourself as an
obstacle and it's bath you get you get
to actually incentivize people did that
I have seen nice to tell the story I've
seen a lot of pedestrians do this sort
of thing so I've seen pedestrians at
crosswalks take a step back and that's
sort of promise drivers to actually take
the right turn because they know that
the person is not actually gonna go do
the anonymous car still has backup
lights but you can scare the heck out of
it yeah so you know this is all the big
limitation of this work is that we've
done this in one human one robot cases
right and so generalizing to multiple
humans is the ends up being being tricky
just because I mean I can always treat
this person as an obstacle but that's
not right like we know that people
aren't just obstacles we know that they
reason about us and so on and so forth
so and then I have to come work in a
much more complicated system plus they
actually might different people on the
road
might actually influence each other so
it just right so this is a big challenge
of how do you actually where do you cut
the cord essential when you deal with
multiple people but at least you know
what is easy to do is not run into other
people so this actually turned it to
work with with real humans which is
great than what I'm excited about is
that you end up with these communication
like strategies when you look at them
you're like okay the car is inching
forward saying I want to go or inching
backwards saying you go et cetera et
cetera you end up with these strategies
that are really useful in coordination
and they're not handcrafted in any way
they fall out of the system that we set
up and the optimization that we do but
again it requires not thinking of people
as doing their thing in isolation
it requires capturing some of this
aspect that people are actually
reasoning about you and responding to
what you do one last thing I want to say
about coordination is that a lot of the
times we do deal with a game of this
sort
other times things are more well behaved
because the human and the robot are on
the same team and you can think of them
as having a shared utility function
right the robot is actually trying to
help the person with a task so it
doesn't have to be quite so adversarial
and then what what we tend to do is
something called coupled planning where
we just you know it's easy to find a
solution to this game you just compute
the optimal over both of the human and
the robot trajectories now what was
interesting is we found that this sort
of this issue of an under actuated
system actually creeps up on you again
because it turns out that in a lot of
such problems people themselves might
not solve the coupled planning problem
perfectly so a specific example of this
is when people do a myopic optimization
where they look only a few steps ahead
as opposed to all of the different steps
ahead right this is an extreme example
where they only look at one
next action but in general you can think
you can see that that people don't
always plan as far ahead into the future
as the robot mind and so when that
happens we're back to this under
actuated dynamics of interaction because
the the robot now needs to reason about
what to do such that when the person
responds myopically that winds up
working well well again for the robot
but now that also is for the person
right they have a shared utility how
does how does this differ from the
situation where the human response
erroneously not even my nut-like not ok
here I'm gonna optimize for the next
step but not the next one which would
have changed how I got there but they
just do something wrong given the
situation good so on one one thing that
we can do there is model people as being
only approximately optimal so allowing
for some irrationality oftentimes we say
well they're not gonna take the best
action they're gonna we're gonna have a
probability distribution over what they
might do of course now you have to plan
an expectation over what am i doing that
kind of complicates things but certainly
that's that would be the right thing to
do if you could sometimes you might be
aware of another kind of bias that
people might have so you know this is
wrong
I mean it's it's wrong in the sense that
it's only correct if the world would end
in one time step right so it is wrong
there are those kinds of biases that
people might have and if you know about
those then you can you can account for
them so what Aaron did is he applied
this to a human robot handover task
where what we found now is that the
robot takes actions that try to guide
the person towards better plans here's a
very simple sort of low-level handover
example of this when you give an object
to a person they will take it somehow
usually in the most comfortable way for
them not necessarily thinking ahead with
what they need to do with that object so
where where exactly they need to place
it if you place an object in a
dishwasher for instance you need to grab
it in a different way than if you place
it to do something else with it so so
and then what might have
that people sort of take the object and
then they have to do something kind of
complicated like extend their arm in a
weird way and kind of incur higher
economic cost or set it down to regress
Pitt or something like that and so when
you run this under actuated system
optimization I skip over that what
actually ends up happening is that the
robot finds a different way to give it
you very uncomfortable for the robot but
we don't care about that there's not
part of the utility all right so should
I want the person responds with this
myopic response right it ends up working
well for them at the goal so that's kind
of I like it's very simple example but I
really love it because it suggests that
robots can take actions that sort of
compensate for our current greediness
myopia etc etc and sort of push us
towards better ways of doing tasks so I
thought that was pretty beautiful so so
far the robot was thinking deeply about
how the person works it turns out that
that people think about how the robot
works too it's a kind of a two-sided
two-sided story and we already mentioned
the hint of that when we discussed how
were giving access to the person to the
whole robot plan for the whole time
horizon and that only works for short
time horizons the reason being people
don't actually know what the robot is
actually going to do next and so we have
a whole line of work in the lab on what
we call expressive or transparent robots
so ways of generating robot actions that
essentially the reason about what the
person is going to think when they get
to actually observe those actions as
opposed to assume that the person can
just guess regardless of what the robot
decides on doing so the trick here is to
treat people as Bayesian in first right
so they take the robots actions and run
Bayesian inference to figure out what on
earth the robot is doing and then you
optimize for that and we do this for
different kinds of domains like goals
and expressing the robots actual utility
to make sure that the person
that the person and the robot are on the
same page and even things like the
robots in capability the robots
limitations should also be very clear to
the person so that they know what
they're going getting themselves into so
overall I'm very excited about what
they've been able to achieve in
coordination clearly there's much more
to to progress on but the steps that
we've been able to take have to lead to
these cool coordination strategies have
all been relying on figuring out how to
capture the game theoretic aspects that
we actually want to capture while
maintaining tractability and these
continuous data in action spaces how
much more time do I have 5-10 minutes
okay so so that's coordination now
throughout all of this we've as well we
assume many things but we've kept on
assuming this thing we kept on a semi
access to a robot utility function
somehow the robot it gets to to have
access to what its utility should be and
so where does this utility come from
well it doesn't fall from the sky it
comes from a person and that is the
robot designer right we're in charge of
determining the robots utility function
and as we make more and more progress on
solving the optimized utility problem we
end up with a bigger and bigger burden
to get the utility function that we are
optimizing right and it turns out that's
a pretty difficult thing to do so this
is a blog post from opening I that
detail their own problems experiences
with designing utility or reward
functions for robots and I'm gonna share
with you their example which I thought
was really interesting this is a boat
that is racing in a game you couldn't
tell that it's racing in the game from
what it's doing this is the the policy
that it came up when the reward function
was number of points in the game you see
that our boat is spinning around here
while other agents are happily actually
racing
the reason our boat is spinning around
here is because there's these turbo
thingies that the boat can collect so it
just found a way to time its loop such
that it can optimally collect the turbo
point thingies and so that's what it
that's what it ends up doing the it
looks like there's a bug but there's not
in that the the boat is is exceptional
at optimizing the utility that we gave
it but therein lies the problem this is
not a new thing
Stuart Russell and Peter Norvig warned
us about that in their book on a I would
give this example of a vacuum cleaning
robot that so they say well imagine you
specify a reward function for this guy
and you say and you say I'm gonna the
rover is gonna be based on how much dust
it sucks in so the more dust it sucks
and sort of presumably the cleaner your
house is and that's a good thing and
then the optimal policy ends up being
suck in a little bit of dust and then
inject it all back so that you can suck
it in again and then inject it all back
right here's a final example this is I
like animation a lot this is Disney
Fantasia
Mickey is a Sorcerer's Apprentice Mickey
gets tasked with essentially filling
this big cauldron of water so he gets
tired of doing the manual chore himself
so you know he uses magic to make it his
own robot assistant so he brings this
broom to life and teaches it the task
right so now we have this assistant that
that whose task it is to go and get
buckets of water from outside go inside
dump them in the cauldron go outside and
so on
and then Mickey goes to bed and I want
to emphasize that when Mickey goes to
bed he transitions from the role of the
designer of this robot assistant to the
role of the end user sort of reaping the
perks of his work right so here's Mickey
asleep while the broom is at work and
it's you know everything's full of water
because well because the
has a reward function which sort of
incentivizes it to bring water into the
house and now what's interesting is that
Miki runs and actually tries to stop the
broom but the broom has a reward
function fine and it is not optimal
according to that reward function to
stop so what's interesting here is that
we're clearly not great at specifying
reward functions for robots so how can
grow but how can we get robots that
perform well despite the fact that we're
not great at specifying these utility
functions what might we do and so this
is the sort of the second thing that I
wanted to mention today to me the prom
starts again because we've been thinking
of the robot in isolation when in fact
there's this designer that comes up with
the with some parameters for the robots
utility right now what we do is we plug
them in and the robot goes off and
optimizes that utility function this is
a little strange because we know that
these parameters are not necessarily the
right parameters and yet the robot just
takes them and completely trusts them
and treat them as I don't know as gospel
so the we think that the first way to
get around this problem is to
acknowledge that whatever the reward
function the person gave you is not
necessarily the correct one the one that
they actually want you to optimize and
therefore the robot has to have you know
a little anxiety a little uncertainty
about the what the actual correct reward
function is so instead of just having
one and saying it's given you actually
have to reason about a probability
distribution over reward functions and
that's easier said and done because how
do I come up with a probability
distribution from just a specified
reward function I could add some
Gaussian noise right but that doesn't
really capture that doesn't really solve
the problem I don't want the robot to be
uncertain about everything right I
wanted to have uncertainty and
right than the right directions I wanted
to kind of reason about what I could
have meant what is plausible that I
could have meant but when I specified
this particular reward and so how do we
come up with such a probability
distribution well what we did is we took
a look at essentially how these problems
might appear in and then what we can
learn from them so we looked at so the
key for us was to look at to answer this
look at where this comes from how what
is the process that produces this and
why is it wrong that's kind of the key
to figuring out what else it could be so
if you think of here's a simplified
version of the boat racing remember the
boat racing looping to get points so
here's a to kind of simplify it down
what essentially happened is that the
boat had access to one policy or
trajectory which would have one with
high number of points but it also had
access in this in this environment to a
policy that got even more points but
lost and it chose that why did it choose
this well because the designer specified
score or number of points as the reward
function so why the designer why did the
designer do that right uh-huh
clearly when we designed reward
functions why would do is we tried him
out a little right we make sure that
across certain scenarios that were
actually envisioning officering
test environments or let's call them
training environments the reward
function leads to the right behavior so
then that tells us something about what
might have happened here right very
likely what happened was that score
actually made sense in the situations
that the person was looking at so if the
person was looking at situations where
either you could win with a lot of
points or you could lose and then get
fewer points and so score was actually a
good reward function and led to the
desired behavior the problem is that a
test time in
you know there's ways to construct
environments where all of the sudden
this this does not end up being the
right thing to do
and so scorn winning they're correlated
at training time but they're no longer
necessarily correlated at test time and
that's how the problem arises you could
probably hack your way through this
turns write something that detects
correlation somehow but that's not the
only way
reward functions can fail here's another
sort of abstract example where we have a
designer who is getting the robot a
navigation robot so the designer sort of
thinks about worlds and says well you
know there's there's roads like dirt
roads or whatever on this campus and
there's grass and I want to sort of make
the robot get to its target but you know
sort of go on grass and not on dirt or
vice versa so how do I do that well
first of all the robot gets acts as some
sort of image or any kind of sensor
information it doesn't know about grass
and dirt and all that so the first thing
that I need to do is I need to sort of
maybe train different different
classifiers that been able to robot to
detect important aspects in the
environment and then I can actually
define a reward function that sort of
says you know grass is bad dirt is good
and that will get the robot to go over
dirt then avoid the grass now what's
interesting is that a test time you
might have options of going through
mostly grass mostly dirt and you might
have options of going through a giant
pit of lava and the robot when it tries
to figure out what to do in this novel
environment you know it will use its
classifiers which haven't been trained
to account for lava and they might you
know they might say this is like grass
or this is like dirt or this is like
nothing it's unclear and they will that
will get lava will get mapped to
something and that's something might
very well have high-reward accidentally
and the robot might choose that so
that's another way that things can go
wrong where I essentially forget about
stuff there's something important that
is not present in the training
environments that we're looking at and
so we forget to kind of include it as a
big deal and the reward but then
appears at test time so how would we
come up with a wit something that can I
can kind of deal with all these
different issues that we might get from
misspecified rewards what we thought of
about here was that there's there's not
much that the robot knows when it gets a
reward function it definitely doesn't
know that that's the right reward
function but it knows this it knows that
the whatever the true reward is so this
if you think about the specified reward
the behavior that that produces in the
training environment has to work well
with respect to the true reward that's
pretty much all you know you don't
really know anything about anything
outside of the training environments
right all you know is that whatever the
person design it probably did well in
the training environment that's the
thing that you can trust another way of
stating the same thing is that the
behavior incentivized by the specified
rewards in these training environments
has high true reward so that's what
we're gonna use what we're gonna do is
we're gonna take the process of reward
design where the person there might be
some parameters that are the right
parameters about the actual person
actually once but they're sort of
implicitly encoded somewhere in the
person's head and the robot doesn't get
to observe that the person tries to
write down something by looking at some
training environments it's not
necessarily the right thing to do so
what we're gonna do is we're gonna try
to invert this we're gonna take that as
an observation and compute based
essentially a Bayesian belief update on
what the true reward might have been
given that we observe this reward and
the big question is what is this right
what is our observation model here and
that's where we use that insight on the
previous slide right the behavior
incentivized by the specified reward in
training has high true reward so that
means that if I try to construct the
probability distribution over what the
person might have said given the
training environments and given the true
thing that is in their head that I don't
get to observe well what I should do is
I should look at the behavior
incentivized by the specified reward in
the training environments
right so if I optimize that in the
training environments what trajectories
do I get and all I know is that it's
likely it's more likely for people to
write down a theta tilde a specified
reward if when I evaluate the behavior
it produces in the true with respect to
the true reward that gets high value it
gets high reward and so that's the
that's the equation we came up with
that's literally the translation of this
inside into an equation to capture how
people might go about writing down these
rewards and now we can actually do
Bayesian inference to figure out what
the true reward might have been and let
me just spend one minute on sort of
conveying why when you do Bayesian
inference with this observation model it
actually enables the robot to figure the
kind of things out that we want it to
figure out so going back to the boat
example where a training time the robot
could win with high points or lose with
low points there are many different
rewards these are just some there are
many different parameters right that the
person could have specified they chose
to specify that you should maximize
score so now instead of the Bayesian
inference setting what the robot is
looking at is which of these right would
have generated maximize score as the
written down reward
well one what the robot does right is it
looks at and this at the behavior
incentivized by the specified reward and
training which is this guy so if you say
max my scored the robot ends up winning
and gets a lot of score at training time
and so now you can say could the person
have meant maximize score well yeah
because when you maximize score that's
good in terms of score good the person
has could the person have meant to
minimize score well no because when I
minimize when when I maximize score I
end up with this and that is does not
vary do very well with respect to low
score being the reward so that's not
gonna work out similarly the robots
gonna know that the person couldn't have
meant that it should be minimizing
winning because again the behavior and
training does not do well with respect
to minimizing win
however when the robot considers
maximising winning that's something that
all of a sudden works because here the
robot ended up having a PI points but
also winning so it is possible that the
person might have meant maximize winning
but actually wrote down score because
that would have led to the same kind of
behavior so that's intuitively the
inference that's happening the the way
we also tested this and again you know I
should say this is very you know the
first part of the talk was like stuff
that we can actually do with robots some
of them or even physical robots they
were doing things this is much more
exploratory but here's what's cool so we
came up with this little navigation
environment and you don't actually eat
this grass and dirt and target and lava
you don't actually get indicators for
this the robot doesn't actually know
what's what it just gets some
observation some noise the observations
about these different types of
environment of cells in the world this
is a training environment where the
person writes down a reward function
that ends up avoiding the grass and and
going on dirt as much as possible and
how do they do that well again they make
classifiers for dirt grass and target
and specify a reward function in terms
of that at test time those classifiers
fire up in all sorts of ways and often
time we found lead the robot to actually
prefer going over lava but if you
actually do this this inverse reward
design inference then the robot is
actually saying okay there what are the
other reward functions define on the
stuff that I have access to which is the
sensor data they would have led to the
same behavior here that would have
produced the same behavior in the
training environment that's all the
robot needs to do I mean there are many
many reward functions that are very
complicated in France when you define
the reward function in the observation
space but fundamentally that's what
enables the robot to actually figure out
that it doesn't actually there are many
other reward functions that could have
worked
and now a test time if we do a
risk-averse planning so we're
conservative with respect to all the
possible rewards that the person could
have meant then we end up actually
avoiding the lava and we see that across
different environments but what's cool
is that I mean the robot doesn't know
about lava it hasn't seen lava ever and
yet it seems to kind of implicitly
figure out that it doesn't know whether
lava is good or bad
lava being a latent thing in the space
that it never gets a label for it never
even gets to see it because remember all
of this is done based on computing a
posterior from the training data that
did not have lava the robot is similarly
uncertain about all sorts of other
things that you might you might you
might throw at it
but what's interesting is that it
captures some probability distribution
of a reward functions and one of them
implicitly penalize is lava like one of
them kind of corresponds to roughly
building a classifier for lava and
penalizing that and the robot realizes
that that would have led to the exact
same behavior a training time and notice
that it's a possibility so risk-averse
planning will actually be will actually
avoid it now do we want to always do
risk averse planning no I mean the goal
of this work was to get a probability
distribution that is in a sense the
right one what the person could have
meant and half the robot understand
those two what a person probably did not
mean we're looking at all sorts of
things we're looking at interaction with
the person going back at them and saying
hey what about this environment you know
did you really mean that I should do
that we also look at stuff like we also
look at so the way you design these
reward functions is by tuning a bunch of
parameters until the robot ends up doing
well across all of your different
environments but with this sort of
inverse reward design idea you could
actually let me skip ahead you could
actually get let the designer specify a
different reward function for each
environment which is much easier you
just have to tune for one environment
and then you treat each of them as
observations about the underlying reward
function that the person wants
and then you come up with your beautiful
posterior over that and you know it
turns out that that does pretty well
there's many different things that we're
exploring based on this idea but again
specified rewards the key is to just
treat them as observations about what
the true reward is good so let me stop
here and just say that yeah here that
you know each of these people play an
important role we have something to
learn from each of them and we have we
need to coordinate with each of them and
that's essentially what my lab is
working on not robots in isolation but
actually accounting enough about people
to be able to get these interactions
right and get robots to be more robust
and deal with our actions can you say
something about how computationally
tractable given a small budget I see my
car right so for the first part of the
talk the this nested optimization that
we're doing we've actually initially
when we were doing it it was close the
real time was that maybe 0.3 seconds per
per plan and you have to do that all the
time nowadays we've got that to be much
lower again by leveraging tricks with
respect to where do you initialize and
doing this kind of iterated procedure as
opposed to recomputing the humans plan
and taking gradients through that every
single time so so you know it's not
cheap for sure it is much more expensive
than making a prediction about the
person and then just running with that
because you don't have any kind of
nested problem there but we've gotten
this to be you know reasonably close to
that performance does it have to be
always on where or can it just be as
moments when
to put this wit and say oh now we need
to go into this you know expensive
awkward it moment yeah very good
question and this is not something that
we've we've started looking at but
certainly I would envision that the car
has to be picky about which which humans
it's actually doing this more
sophisticated reasoning one in which
humans it just you know there's there's
kind of so on influenceable and far away
that you don't even attempt at this
absolutely and you can you can kind of
see ways that you could kind of learn
that right from from previous experience
you can just simulate a lot of
environments and sort of try to make
that classification but that's not
something that we've done yet find an
equilibrium but that would find an
equilibrium only with you know with
certain kind of utility functions so in
general it'll it's not going to give you
an equilibrium so what are the practical
applications of actually not not having
an equilibrium yeah so I mean basically
the trade-off the the sort of the
sacrifice that we're making is that
we're sort of assuming that the person
is just gonna accept the robots plan and
first of all know it but second of all
accept the robots plan and just computer
best response to that right whereas in
real life people will actually try to
influence what the robot will do bias
that's the part that we sacrifice and so
in a lot of situations and because we
also have and this is the question that
you asked right because we have these
different driver types and we can
actually adapt to the the driver that
almost sort of obfuscates this problem
it doesn't actually solve it but you
know it's just that in practice it turns
out that thinking of people as
aggressive best response but aggressive
is close enough to modeling them as if
they're trying to be play the game and
influence you another thing that we've
explored and it's not published work yet
we're still working on it but I'll just
mention that we I have a student Jaime
who is exploring the solving the game
the actual game
some higher level where the dynamics are
much more simple and then using the
value as guiding heuristic to do with a
sort of simple best response thing at
the low level so that can capture at
least parts of the fact of the person is
trying to influence you we've had some
success with that especially in terms of
being able to expand the planning
horizon good so people are definitely
trying that and then there's two ways to
go about it one of the ways is called
behavior cloning where you collect a lot
of demonstrations and you try to
directly learn a policy meaning a
mapping from state to action based on
human data the challenge there is you're
right you don't have the whole planning
apparatus to be able to explain humans
decisions that they might take now for
things that might happen in the future
so it's like not trying to learn a
reward function but trying to learn a
value function directly value functions
tend to be much more complicated and
therefore that means your sample
complexity to be able to do that is
quite high so the moment you so what
you'll do is you'll interpret it pretty
well among the the training data that
you have but what we worry about is
extrapolation to being when you take an
outside of that environment a second way
to approach this is to not learn a
policy directly but learn a cost
function and still rely on optimization
so this kind of goes into this issue of
defining the utility one one answer for
that is you let the person Drive you
treat that as evidence about their
underlying utility and you adopt that as
the utility and that at least helps you
figure out what the straight-up should
be instead of setting them by hand
right and this is essentially what we've
done because we
we we did it for people as a way to
model how people drive we also did it
for the robot because we didn't know how
to set all these different parameters by
hand so we ended up actually learning
from demonstrations that's another way
of teaching and exploiting human data
but still actually leveraging the
optimization mechanism so it's like a
natural byproduct of you know training
these like human utility models is
learning a lot about human behavior that
maybe we don't already know
geographically democratically you know
learn things that we don't already know
do you agree that that's a natural
byproduct yeah I think it teaches us
about human utility and one of the
things that we've explored for instance
is for more difficult questions about
the reward function so you know people
talk about trolley problems but the sort
of the physical manifestation of that is
sometimes you get into situations where
there is going to be an accident and you
have to figure out no matter what you do
and you have to figure out the sort of
the best choice and in a sense you know
I don't feel like it's up to me to
define what that best choice is and so
I'd love to learn to let a person make
that decision and so then when I
actually try to learn by exposing people
to different alternatives extract from
their answers they're a general utility
function that can generalize over
different situations I can kind of probe
at well what are the trade-offs that
people are making and indeed what does
that teach us about human values or
human ethics seems like this process
become more automated with time right
increasingly the human participant will
be removed
you know the ki becomes more and more
self-learning so it seems like at some
point in the future and you know what
we're learning about human behavior will
dramatically accelerate right hopefully
um hopefully I mean I think you'll still
always have to deal with human behavior
because you're working making robots
that are supposed to deal with people
but you know hopefully robots will get
better and better at figuring people out
without you know and relying on as much
data and so on and hopefully we'll be
able to make these findings
interpretable I mean I think that's one
challenge here that if I am to train you
know one thing that we've explored is a
cost function that's represented as and
you're on that and the challenge there
is that you know then I have a
predictive model of people but I don't
actually understand so since its latest
give the jokes about the robot overlords
and implants when you we need when you
go back and try to learn from the right
circle together are you trying to to
learn your loss function and you
parameterize your loss function and you
learn the loss function from the
training that would happen yes you learn
your loss function from not just the
training but also the loss function that
the person thought it would be a good
idea start with the best event
[Music]
maybe we shouldn't have done this kisses
little strange but when you're playing
another game like poker and you wind up
determining that your opponent is a
certain type and there's sort of only a
few types of players in order and you
then let them know that you know what
type they are it can wind up influencing
their behavior so in the co-operative
example letting the truck driver know
that you know that they're an aggressive
driver could potentially influence their
behavior or not to be is there is that
too many layers deep in the inner
planning or is there some is there some
way to sort of other than the blinker
could say not just blinker but I believe
you this is what you're gonna do when I
start moving yeah um I
yeah you can I think I think we can
definitely display predictions to people
so if we found a way to basically beam
them to their car or something and that
that will influence their behavior and
I'm I'm thinking through oh now I need
to actually like be able to capture
somehow what this change will be is that
I figure out what's a good thing for me
to display to them which is the typical
poker thing I think in a sense the game
we're playing is how can we capture what
we need and clearly we need some things
without going all the way to the full
partially observable stochastic game
settings that's like